journalism is under attack like never
before no
tear gas fire you have to have the facts
beautiful but tragic because people are
doubting everything you're the only way
of telling their story how would you
describe this outbreak something like an
apocalypse you're going to be really
tired you're going to be really scared
it's too dangerous anyone who says
they're not scared is life
anything can happen
did you get here i sometimes wonder how
have we managed to get out of
this we do genuinely believe in what we
do it's clearly martial press to show
the truth wow this is absolutely
unbelievable to uncover an injustice
this is the result of ethnic cleansing i
don't think any journalist wants
anything more than that i'm alex
crawford i'm stuart ramsey and this is
hot spots
coming up on hot spots we're in paradise
we're in namibia where plans to drill
for oil are threatening some of the
world's most precious and endangered
wildlife we don't know what the effect
of that oil and our environment we are
afraid for that
and over a decade since an earthquake
ravaged haiti we revisit to find a
country on a knife edge the atmosphere
was really tense
there's a bullet green fight we're
trying to carry the streak
it was a sort of david and goliath
battle and nature the human battle they
basically got an oil drill in their
backyard he feels that you've counted
legally on his land what's he going to
do he's nobody
every environmentalist we spoke to was
horrified about doing any oil
exploration there are hundreds of
thousands of elephants that depend on
this river because there just aren't
that many places left in the world like
that
[Music]
[Music]
namibia is a land of extremes
you are blown away by this mixture of
climates and environments and landscapes
it's like a film set
it not only had the biggest sand dunes
in the world it's got a coast right
along the atlantic that's called the
skeleton coast because they're still
finding the bones of animals and humans
and pirates and travelers still washing
up there i mean it's a land of
mystery
environmental wonders
absolutely jaw-droppingly gorgeous
i thought there was a
an astonishing story there which seemed
to encapsulate everything that a
journalist might want in a story it was
a sort of david and goliath battle a
nature v human battle
recon africa also known as
reconnaissance africa are a canadian
oil company which believed that the
kevanga basin and the kavango river was
sitting on this huge undiscovered oil
field
downstream of that
several hundred miles one of the globe's
most drop dead gorgeous wildlife
environmental sites the okavango delta
which is home to
hundreds of different species of birds
fauna flora
wildlife
every environmentalist we spoke to
was horrified about the idea of doing
any oil exploration within a few hundred
miles of one of the world's natural
treasures
it was my first
story it was my first story with skye it
was my first story of kevin and alex
and you know you want to make a good
impression
we'd got a new member of the team in the
middle of this pandemic so we hadn't
even been able to meet as a team that's
it we knew chris was experienced but we
weren't we weren't sure if
if uh you know if he would necessarily
get us or how he would operate
the excitement was building we were
gonna go i went and did my pcr test
and it came back positive two days
before we were meant to go and be
meeting for the first time and doing
this their first story together so that
was a massive anti-climax
and all of a sudden you think oh god
like
what what do we do where do we go what
what no what happens now
kev and chris had both already arrived
in namibia and they were just waiting
for me to turn up
it's a good start in it yeah it's not
the best start in the world but there we
go in the days while we were waiting for
alex to arrive we decided to head to
swakopmund the coast
we were looking at all sorts of stories
and taking opportunities to film
potentially for those stories in the
future we should be this close it
doesn't feel right
all the time i was getting pictures sent
back to me from kevin and chris saying
oh look where we are and look what we're
doing
not much not much to see here at all
yeah they were very sympathetic
i was really jealous what are you
kidding i had to sit and watch them for
a good week it was a horrible situation
without you know without the boss
arriving at the airport here she comes
it's one of those moments you know it's
not you know there's no two ways about
it you're gonna feel the pressure
chris was coming into a new company a
whole new set of people how's it going
to carry all my facts
i thought it's worth a try
he took it quite well actually as we
packed up i said um that's it
yeah holiday
when you're opening a book on how to
pick a new teammate and get on the very
first thing on the first page i bet you
won't find do a seven-hour long car
journey where no one can get away
how long have we got to go chris
i think five hours
so we've done two hours yeah another we
had a lovely drive to get to know each
other and
get to know alex's
terrible taste of music i can't help
liking the best balladeer of all time
apologies for that but we headed first
of all to
what we felt was the crux of the story
which was the mouth of the okavango
delta
we had a long-standing contact with an
environmentalist and a lodge owner joffy
who was operating in that area
so how are you
wonderful
we're in paradise here
you soak up his enthusiasm and his love
of nature this is what to call another
tough day in africa yeah that's just
what i was thinking and he's opening our
eyes to things that
you don't normally see
in the river is a hippocrates place
we should see some wildlife here on this
island up ahead and lots of lecture
hippos raising themselves out of the
water
going up and seeing this huge crocodile
which seemed to just wait for us to get
up there and then slowly slide in
you probably go about seven foot
you'll hurt any one of us probably kill
any one of us on the boat
joffy didn't let any moment go unused to
remind me about the link between
something that was happening you know
several hundred miles away and the
impact it could have downstream
thousands of elephants
hundreds of thousands elephants that
depend on this river to survive his
point was
this will all change if we have oil
found they're saying this is a bigger
oil field than saudi arabia is it not
perhaps you have to look at the bigger
picture and how that would
massively
transform africa it comes back down to
the basics of how nature will be
affected what's the environmental impact
going to be what's going to be the
detrimental impacts to
free-flowing water underground water
wildlife animals killed on roads and
then built also obviously a huge influx
of people coming in from all over the
world to
you know extract these things namibia
and botswana are sort of home to
the largest
remaining herd of savannah elephants
so at first five in the morning
and
we're going on a game drive
try and see some elephants
inside this park
is a place of particular sanctuary and
refuge for these elephant herds
the elephant cows and calves like coming
down to this area here because it's nice
and open
they buffalo down there too
there's a little bit of anxiety in the
group because we have got a sort of time
scale
so we need the elephants to come out on
this day
at this time
you heard those elephants just in
[Music]
here to try and get elephants no but uh
it hasn't been particularly hot today so
that if they don't have to
walk a long way to water their work
first couple of times we went out we saw
incredible sights but no elephants and
this was meant to be one of the key
parts of the story this migratory route
of the savannah elephant and we couldn't
find any of the goddamn things so we're
on our way to the watering hole which is
where we're hoping to see the elephant
this
we were being taken to all the obvious
places
they were just eluding us
we were seeing signs that they'd been
there all fresh droppings the poop
elephant poo
my favorite subject
there's 56 percent of whatever you eat
comes out undigested it's a waste right
right no everything else eats this sorry
no
i can tell you i've become the world
expert in the elephant poo
and those elephants eat mygetting nuts
and they transport them 100 kilometers
in gum deposit them here
so that just shows the vast distances
that these animals move because this
whole area here is open they can go
wherever they want and he used it to
illustrate just how dependent these
elephants are on these migration routes
and if this huge billion dollar oil
project was going to cut right across
this migration route and it was going to
impact on
this largest surviving herd of africa's
savannah elephants
and then we finally came across a whole
load of them
[Music]
that little feeling you have of whoa
this is this is pretty special these
incredible creatures are very sensitive
to sound to movement
and the worry is that they will be
frightened away
i felt a real sense of wonderment
there's this
huge area with beautiful wild creatures
and the idea that it could all be
spoiled because of a drive for money and
a drive for business just seems in many
ways really crazy because there just
aren't that many places left in the
world like that
[Music]
[Applause]
well
it's still pretty dark out there
we woke before dawn and we're planning
to head out early
we had to go and see what was happening
at the oil exploratory area an area
called the kavango basin
underneath the kevanga basin this oil
and gas company believed that
there was one of the world's biggest
undiscovered oil fields
it was a few hours drive to get to this
really remote
area
but heading there it's just so lush and
green
and then you get to this
village and immediately you can see the
impact that this team is having there
you know it was just this industrial
blot on what was basically untouched in
nature
the north of namibia is
the poorest area in the country really
poverty strips you i think of of any
power it makes you extremely vulnerable
we went into the communities around the
drill site you know to meet locals those
that were most directly affected
andreas was the sort of patriarchal
figure of a very small extended family
they've basically got an oil drill in
their backyard you can literally hear
them drilling from here he is a
subsistent farmer with a small plot of
land he's got a few crops he's got a bit
of you know he's got a bit of land for
his animals to graze on
and that's it that's how he lives that's
how he survives
and this is your maze
this is your maze
so it was that your land
and suddenly this big foreign company
had set up shop in his back garden
basically
and
transformed it into this big
oil exploration site
andreas wanted to show us just how close
the oil exploration site was
all this one in his land all of this is
his land he's saying
this is quite something to have in your
back garden
it's just yeah he's talking about
rubbing his face in it you know this
thing he's just got to look at every
single day on his land
are you saying you feel like you've been
robbed
he knew very little about what was going
on
just that
his version was that
one day
they weren't there one day they came and
what's he going to do he's nobody
and when we got to the edge of it he was
just showing how close it was to us and
we could see people there and i think
almost certainly they could see us
we didn't believe that we were
trespassing because we were on what
andreas believed was his land
and then these oil i presume they were
some sort of managerial people came out
towards us they're perfectly polite i
just came to ask if you would uh back up
beyond the berm
uh you're you're actually within the
parameters of our location
can you tell us some how close you are
to finding oil i'll tell you what i can
take your phone number and i can get
your information to the right people
where they can answer your questions
okay i don't have the answer to that do
you feel hopeful or what what is your
feeling about how successful you're
likely to be in finding oil
i'm going i can take your information
and get it to the right oh come on just
give me throw me a bone here
we're drilling for information this is
andreas
he actually
lives on this land
and and he feels that you've camped
illegally on his on his lap
to the right person
would you like to say anything to him
end of conversation we followed up
afterwards and chris got in touch with
the company they gave a very full
statement saying that they were taking
lots of environmental precautions that
nothing had been discovered yet that the
future was in
the hands of the namibian people and the
namibian
government
that they were
very environmentally conscious
[Music]
andreas was just one person there were
many hundreds you know around the site
who felt equally
worried and didn't know what their
futures were going to hold and what are
your worries though we don't know what
the effect of that oil
and our environment
we are afraid for that
when you're sitting in a hut
where
you can see what they're going to eat
that night and it's a pile of leaves
and they they're talking about you know
feeling utterly powerless they feel like
they're not being heard it's really
difficult not to feel some sort of
empathy with them how much consultation
has there been about it all now
they didn't tell us that what would if
the effect will be whether it would be
destroying environment or not they did
not explain that for us
one of the things that recon africa had
done to try and win over the population
in an area which is so water scarce was
to drill a borehole quite close so that
they didn't have to do this huge long
trek to get water
and they were grateful for those but the
general sense was that these foreigners
had come had
offered help talked a tiny bit about
what they were doing
but then nothing you know they had no
information what was going on they
didn't know what impact
the exploration was going to have for an
outsider's point of view it slightly
smacks of giving them a little bit of
help which they desperately need and on
the other hand you know
still pressing ahead with this huge
multi-million dollar project
so he's not known as a chief he's head
man
we got a completely different
perspective when he went to see one of
the tribal leaders is that him
i got the impression straight away
through body language and his demeanor
he thought we were foreign interlopers
who were basically coming to preach to
him
what's happening
he's finding someplace for us to come
and talk
he didn't seem best pleased to talk to
us but he
did invite us in and set us down
his retort to
our questions was very much on the lines
of well it's all right for you because
you are rich and educated and privileged
and you've got careers and you've got
jobs what why are you trying to hold us
back
you feel people are trying to stop you
from getting better getting
richer
he definitely made us think in a
different way
their lives were mired in poverty you
know their kids were not being schooled
they were scrapping around for food
every day so to him the oil exploration
represented something very very
different a better future you know a
future where they could be educated and
they could eat properly
it just comes down to
how much you believe or want to believe
in the idea that
this wealth that is
potentially going to be found is going
to actually trickle down
to the people living
on the ground at the moment they have
very little anyway so you can imagine if
anything goes wrong it's just going to
be chaos for them you know
if the if the soil is polluted that's it
you know
they can't live off the land because
that's just ruined
the very nature of environmental stories
you're trying to illustrate something
which hasn't yet happened so you can't
film
destruction and devastation which the
locals are
worried about because it hasn't happened
uh this is the um
you somehow have to capture the
imagination of
as many people as possible people who
wouldn't necessarily want to watch an
environmental report or people who have
absolutely zero interest in oil
exploration the impact here will be
significant you're aware that not
everyone is interested in the
environment outside of their own small
environment so
whenever you do these stories it's it's
obviously we hope it's going to be
impactful recon africa's oil exploration
licenses cover thousands of square
kilometers i think it was my daughter
who said oh my god mum leo has tweeted
about your story and it was like leo
who's leo and it's like leonardo
dicaprio has noticed your story has
tweeted it and of course he has got
millions and millions of followers
when quite a big celebrity notices the
story we've just done
yeah that's quite something and i know
alex was as giddy as a little school
girl
maybe he'll make a film about it we did
try and get him to be interviewed but he
was busy
even if you've got these ranks of people
and celebrities like leonardo dicaprio
all lined up saying there's going to be
a disaster please stop please stop
there's going to don't do that don't
ruin it it's it's very hard to
to
get action before something has actually
happened
[Music]
recon haven't yet
managed to prove
that there is oil
in the kavango basin especially not on
the scale that they are
projecting
the big question
is
their oil
if the answer to that question is yes
and you've got all these difficult
decisions to be made as do you exploit
it how do you exploit it once you are
exploiting it
you're open to
accidents
sabotage
disasters
just general pollution
are we going to be doing stories about
how namibia has been transformed by this
oil discovery and got riches beyond
their wildest dreams and everyone now in
namibia is educated and got a great
house to live in that's another way the
story could go there's no telling right
at the moment
well i really hope we're not going to be
doing a story about how devastated the
okavango delta is in 10 years time that
would be
that would be horrific
[Music]
up next
it had been a period of chaos on the
streets
extreme violence on the streets
we went with some trepidation we're back
at it this is what we do
[Music]
it was a massive worldwide story when
the earthquake hit the world is going to
an end
after 10 years and it looks just the
same incredible
the mass protest was really a call to
action
[Music]
this has been going on there for hours
everybody knew about haiti the day after
the earthquake everybody has forgotten
about hating now
[Music]
we had actually been traveling to
guatemala on a series of stories that
we've been working on for a while when
it became clear that haiti was a story
that perhaps we should have a look at
[Music]
we started looking at it with increased
interest over a number of days
if you might be going to haiti then yeah
just trying to find someone who might be
able to work with us we sort of saw the
haiti story but it seems
quite quickly so
you covered the earthquake yeah
anyway send out a good old-fashioned
email to someone and see what comes back
there was this date coming up the 7th of
february which was the date the
opposition was saying that the president
needed to step down and it'd been a lot
of protest build up leading up to that
date
we didn't know
really what to expect but we did know
that it had been a period of
a fair amount of chaos on the streets
extreme violence on the streets
we went i think with some trepidation
but thinking well we could actually see
a coup take place
[Music]
it was over a decade to be back in haiti
and that was an enormous earthquake this
whole place i mean the airport hasn't
changed much
it'll be interesting to see what it's
like in porter price
i think even within the first few
minutes of us leaving the airport we
realized how dangerous tense and
changing the situation
was
our driver etienne was looking at his
map router all the time on his app
there's trouble ahead
you would see where roads are suddenly
being closed by gangs taking over areas
so listen we've got a political crisis
is the president going to leave or is he
going to continue what do you think i
don't know but at the street the people
needs him to go
right
and they don't have hospital they don't
have
work it's not safe
all countries are kidnapping kidnapping
kidnapping it's not good
we passed by youth standing around
trying to blockade areas of the city
[Music]
arm gangs around apparently and a lot of
people on the street
we're just trying to get out of
this particular area and get to the
hotel
this has been chaotic already
so um that was quite an interesting trip
from the airport
fast
burning barricades closed off roses and
police on high alert
and we've literally been in haiti about
20 minutes
we're back at it this is what we do
[Music]
puerto prince is possibly one of the
most
impoverished
dirty
foul
dangerous places that i've ever been to
it's not been helped by the fact that
the earthquake
caused so much damage to its
infrastructure an infrastructure that
hasn't actually been replaced as far as
i can tell virtually anywhere
we spoke to brunelli who's our producer
in haiti what's interesting is being
here
after 10 years and it looks just the
same
yeah
yeah i'm not saying if anything it's
probably worse
yeah
usually town centers of a capital are
probably the nicest part of a country
and this was just
absolutely trashed and brunelli as we
would drive would point out say right
that area is controlled by that gang
that area is controlled by that rival
gang there might be barricades and
roadblocks because there's a series of
gangs along the way that might block the
axis
everyone's just used to such over
violence and so much
dog eats dog
that everywhere you go
you have that sense of everyone needs
something
and if they see an opportunity to take
it off anybody who's weak they will do
[Music]
in a collapsing economy
with gangs running
pretty much all the streets
[Music]
the government is accused and widely
accepted to be corrupt
with no infrastructure rebuilding
the biggest growing business is
kidnapping
you would expect it to affect the rich
but they also kidnap poor people
and
ask for very small amounts of money in
relative terms but actually they will
kill those people if the ransom isn't
paid
it's becoming such a big business that
anyone literally on the street is in
danger all the time so the communities
have decided to protect themselves and
so streets will be closed off and they
will do it with anything
we came across these barricades at
almost every point of interest in the
city
the protests have been against the
president giovanna luisi who is known as
juvenile by everyone
the problem is there is no work for
anyone so it's just a sort of a survival
economy and that is why the abduction of
people has become such big business
it's the biggest growth business in in
haiti today
it was a massive worldwide story when
the earthquake hit
[Music]
it took forever to get in because
for a moment the airport was open and
then the united states took control of
the relief operation and it was closed
[Music]
the sky team came in by road across from
dominican republic
what did the aftershocks hit and the off
shocks were big and we our hotel was
already
damaged and rocking a bit so
when the afternoon we'll just go out
into the garden and try to sleep there
[Music]
the reason why it's so destructive is
because it was so near the surface
but also the infrastructure here is
never going to be built well enough so
everything just tumbled down
i remember bodies on the street that
stayed there for days and days and days
while we were working
[Music]
don't underestimate the desperation here
this distribution of tiny amounts of
rice descends into chaos almost
immediately
they aren't starving they just don't
know if there's any more to come
out here nobody's told them anything
we didn't have
a deployment anywhere near as big as
most of our opposition
in truth it was down to two reporters
the medical emergency crisis is going on
but look at this thousands upon
thousands of people with nowhere to go
they're sleeping rough out here
this is a humanitarian crisis and it's
growing every day
within our trip i wanted to leave porto
prince i wanted to go to a place called
lee again which i'd visited in the
earthquake and we were trying to see
how it had changed
this is lee again or rather it was
90 percent of the town collapsed in the
earthquake
it beggars belief but this all happened
in just seven seconds just seven
well we've come to uh
delay again which was the epicenter of
the earthquake
it was very
shallow it was more like an explosion
and uh while i was reporting here it
came across a little girl who had had
her hand amputated
sandina pierre is five she's in agony
her mother can't watch her little girl
suffer anymore
a night ago a trainee nurse amputated
her hand without anesthetic there were
no doctors
stuart had been there during the
earthquake and he was quite
keen to see what it looked like now
anything looking familiar
[Music]
so this is where everyone was brought
and they were treated here
[Music]
i think it was also one of the most
secure areas that they had
thousands are living rough in tented
villages in football grounds pretty much
anywhere
they're injured and they're grieving
you've got to remember
that this town was smashed
smacked
anything that's still standing isn't
quite remarkable or anything that's been
rebuilt there's a big change on
port-au-prince
[Music]
we drove to the beach and this is the
thing about haiti is it's just an
extraordinarily beautiful coastline it's
a caribbean country it could be with its
pristine beaches one of the you know top
tourist attractions in the world but
it's not because of all of its other
issues
[Music]
oh
and i remember talking to this youngster
who was very nice guy
so you were here in the earthquake did
you lose family and friends
my
and he just wanted to actually make the
point that aide had come in
they'd been
given temporary housing and he was still
living in that temporary house
none of the building that they've been
promised and none of the development
that had been promised and none of the
money that had been given had been used
to change their lives
i remember my own family donated money
loads of people in britain donated money
and around the world
what happened to that money we are
talking
billions of dollars worth of aid into
haiti after this dreadful enormous
earthquake took place
and there's almost nothing to show for
it
[Music]
and he was very very forthright in his
anger
he was sort of a natural politician but
he was the only person who was really
happy to speak to us
because he just wanted to make the point
that you know things need to change and
that they want political change and they
want civil change in the country
and there's nothing to indicate to us as
far as we can tell that that is going to
happen anytime soon
i think
it brought our story sort of around a
bit full circle because we knew so many
people were protesting we knew so many
people were frustrated and this young
man just so eloquently described why
everybody knew about haiti the day after
the earthquake everybody has forgotten
about haiti now
[Music]
all right well this has hardly changed
since uh the earthquake sort of like
done
was really chaotic when we were here so
coming past the cathedral i remember it
being distinctly
well destroyed but
there were so many other things to look
at people suffering and
so
you know you concentrated more on
on people and hospitals and people
living rough and trying to find water
and food because there was there was
nothing
and i remember that people getting angry
and angry because there were huge
amounts of supplies huge numbers of
doctors
everything you need in the airport which
is only down the road and nobody got any
of it for days and days and days
the conditions just deteriorated
i think the cathedral represents a
failure a failure to address
basic infrastructure rebuilding that
needed to take place
it sort of feels like a metaphor for
everything the country's demise the
disaster the
ruins
and all around it
shanty towns that didn't exist before
incredible
there's definitely a sense of something
here no you can sort of
[Applause]
so it tells a story
loss
yeah a lot of it
yeah 250 000 people
[Music]
[Music]
there were mass protests called for the
7th of february this was the day the
opposition said that president muay said
who was in power
needed to step down
it's quite a complicated situation he
was voted in a contested election so he
didn't take over
his presidency for a year while the
contest continued
he says that that year
needs to be added on to the end of
his current term which meant that you
have the opposition party saying
well you had your term and it's ended
he has so many economic problems it has
high unemployment and so the mass
protest was really a call to action on
their part to say right let's do
something about this and put our
government under pressure
we
thought it was going to be a huge rain
police are down there
it would set fires in the middle of
roads anywhere that they felt that they
could get some type of advantage
[Music]
the police were really on it the whole
day it looks like the uh police are
putting in their water cannon and their
men this is around the original
presidential palace which collapsed in
the earthquake it's never been rebuilt
this is the area they don't allow the
demonstrators to come down
so they're creating their sort of
defensive position now
the crowds are trying to gather
but it's not working because the police
keep
breaking them up
[Music]
there's quite a lot of tear gas being
fired at various times
tear gas is really unpleasant but a very
good crowd controller
we had our gear with us and the great
thing about gas miles is that you can
actually operate really quite well when
tear gas is all around you
atmosphere was really tense
there were rocks and stones and glass
being thrown everywhere
one of the worst things about covering
any type of riot is where you should be
you would think ostensibly being behind
the police would be a good place to be
the other way of looking at it is being
with the protesters
bear in mind the police are firing live
rounds
as well as tear gas
and then of course there's the middle
which is never a great place to
be and so you can actually just find
yourself absolutely stuck and i've been
in it many many times
this has been going on there for hours
setting fire to buildings
trying to get around groups
come along
suddenly it seemed like almost
everywhere was a no-go zone
the phantom 509 is blamed for an awful
lot of this but there are other gangs
as well one a particularly nasty gang of
group of gangs is called the g9 they
terrorize neighborhoods
they are
largely controlled by a guy called
barbecue
his name is barbecue because of his
nasty way of dealing with his opponents
and this is an area that's been attacked
before by government forces
it's because of this type of crime that
people want the president to leave what
happens if he doesn't leave
be
oh [ __ ] here we go
dan
had gone forward and i think he actually
filmed facing backwards
we didn't actually have other marks on
at that point so he was like
joking at the same time
young boy comes up and he's like been
breathing in the fumes
and it was a great shot it's the type of
shot that you know every cameraman is
wanting to take
did you get it yeah uh no we had a bit
when it was coming down
you all right
ultimately my job is to be part of the
filming process but it's also the
writing process so what events we see i
have to edit down into a coherent story
especially if you go to countries like
haiti where people have absolutely no
idea what's going on there in the
general outside world this was a day
promising revolution against president
mohisa
but each day this country already one of
the poorest in the world is sliding into
absolute anarchy stuart ramsey sky news
haiti
you don't do the reports if you don't
think they'll have impact i mean that's
what you spend your whole time working
on is to make sure that you make a point
that people actually care about
i'd like to say that i think that
haiti's future is looking up but the
truth is i really don't think it is
there are
issues rooted in so much poverty so much
corruption so much crime
its biggest problem right now gangs
because they are taking over and the
proper democratic processes
are being overwhelmed by the prevalence
of the gangs and for ordinary people
that is really horrendous
[Music]
next time on hot spots we knew that
there were communities that were
struggling to eat we're in guatemala
where the climate crisis is causing
people to either flee or starve
they have to make this terrible choice
and my team witnessed the devastation
left by terrorists after they launched a
deadly assault in mozambique it was very
eerie
they were tied with their hands behind
their back and their heads were cut off
okay
until then you can find us on twitter at
alex crawford sky and at ramsey sky
see you next time
as you are
as you were
as i want you to be
as a friend
as a friend
as an old into me
[Music]
you